Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number,
if you want to call in. That number is
two one nine two David Pakman. Any time during
the Trump rally on Saturday, we talked about
this group, Blacks for Trump, they wear shirts
that say Blacks for Trump. They are black,
the individuals mostly. And we've talked about
how it is a common thing at Trump rallies
that the few black attendees are placed
very conspicuously on stage behind Trump.
Here's a caller who tried to figure
out who who are blacks for Trump,
and he didn't come up with much. Take a listen.
Speaker 5: Hi, Mr. President. My name is
Alfredo Gomez Bows. And I was watching your show
and I just had a question for you. You showed
this video of Trump just recently at a rally,
but this is today's 1927. 2021. Yeah. And there
is a bunch of people that have blacks for Trump
T-shirts that are in white with black letters
and they're black people. And I was just wondering
if you could give us a take on that. Why is that
happening? I looked up blacks for Trump, Starcom
nothing. I looked up blacks for Trump's. Really,
I don't see anything. So I was just wondering if
maybe you could enlighten us on something that
I love watching your show and remember
and thank you so much for putting the
word out. There is a reality. Thank you.
Speaker 1: So, listen, I've been treading a little
bit carefully about the blacks for Trump thing,
because if you do a search for blacks for Trump,
you will find a lot of articles about one of
the individuals involved with blacks for Trump.
But there's very little about this supposed group.
And I don't want to you know, it feels wrong to
me and disqualifying to just basically say if
there are black people at a Trump rally, clearly
it's Astroturf or they've been paid. I don't have
evidence of that. The fact that there is so little
about blacks for Trump as a stand alone group with
anything other than just appearing at rallies and
part of their sort of repertoire makes me wonder
very much about the sort of veracity that this
is. This is a real group. Every time we do a rally
and blacks for Trump, people are up behind Trump.
I get emails from people saying, look, David, the
Trump campaign, the Trump team is known for hiring
people to go to rallies. Here's a Craigslist post
of when they advertise. I get it. I'm not ready to
say the group is totally made up. There are black
Trump supporters, but Trump supporters exist.
I'm not going to just say, you know, it just it
seems problematic to to just write off a group,
a minority group, a historically oppressed group
and say what they purport to be. Their political
views aren't real. And clearly it's made up. I'm
not going to do that. But there are real questions
about what exactly blacks for Trump is and sort of
what to what extent it exists as an organization.
I encourage you to look it up. Maybe at some point
we'll get some kind of more definitive answer.
We have a great bonus show for you today. How
do you get the bonus show? I wish I knew. Now,
I do know you sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom today
on the bonus show. We will talk about the anti VAX
push in the NBA. Actually seems to be working to
push the league around a little bit. We'll talk
about LeBron James saying I did what was right for
my family and that was get vaccinated. We'll talk
about other players saying no. We will talk about
mail delivery, about to get permanently slower and
more expensive. Why you can probably guess. And
lastly, following up on our Monday story, a judge
has ruled that New York City can go forward with
its vaccine mandate for educators and staff in the
New York City school system. All of those stories
and more will be on today's bonus show. Sign up at
Unidentified: Join Pakman
Dotcom, speak to you about.